[Musik]
super Idee das
transparentar gut ich sicher
nicht Geld und Politik zum ersten Mal
will die Schweiz da transparent sein
offenlegen W W was bezahlt in einem
wlkamp ist das nötig oder unnötige
Bürokratie
riesen
Schw
stundingen
irgendwie prüft die
Behörde ist neu das ist aber es ist für
andere das kontrolli ne was für einen
ein hat bei
wen
mitor nicht ganz genau
[Musik]
interessiert mit diesen Fragen sind wir
unterwegs im Schweizer
Wahljahr g
und
abh
[Musik]
es ist Mitte Februar 8 Monate vor den
Wahlen ich habe abgemacht mit dem
Präsidenten der Grünen grüß GL grü darf
noch das
Mikrofon Baltasar glattli hat einen
liveaftritt im Fernsehen Thema die
Wahlschlappe vom Wochenende im Kanton
Zürich das erste Mal seit dem großen
Sieg vor 4 Jahren geht's
bergab jetzt sag ich w Chef von
Sportmannschaft und sind letzt Jahr
Meister und das s
n
H Grund zum
Panik Zen und nicht haltenft
veren
traineruswechsler genau genau ist das
das Thema be euch das ist jetzt genau
der Punkt dass ich muss l dass man mich
nicht awechselt dann im Herbst apropos
Fußball dort heißt es Erfolg lässt sich
kaufen ich will von gladli wissen ob das
in der Politik auch funktioniert Geld
bringt dannis wenn man gut die Botschaft
hat wenn man ein Überzug der Inhalt
überzeugende Inhalt hat wenn man das
nachher Stärke kan h genug
als grünne sind wir ja immer eine von
der Ärmste wenn die Ärmste Partei von
der große und dem Jahres zum Glück
anders was er hier antönt wird der
später enthüllen eine Millionen schwere
mezenen wird die Grünen in diesem
Wahlkampf
unterstützen mit Geld führt man glatt
nicht aufs glatte aber sie
Fr
das ist so also jetzt jah und zw nicht
ich jetzt finde das
ist
oder Köpfe und Botschaften das muss bei
Wahlen und Abstimmungen unters
volkum weich Stelle für Zukunft undö
sind redaktionelle auftte sind
goldent Wahlkampf viel Geld das ist fr
oder wieder nach
links Transparenz ist das Gebot im
Hinblick auf die altgenössischen
wahigentlich für den W von
Kand alle gleichermaßen begeistert von
der
transparenzte die Schweiz und R Land des
geldste atinen in der Politik alles
geheimhten kein anderes Land in Europa
lie das so zu außer Belarus mit Diktator
Lukaschenko nun haben also auch wir ein
Gesetz für Transparenz in der
politikfinanzierung der internationale
Druck hat warschinlich mit der große
Rolle gespielt Greco das ist so eine
Organisation wo quasi für Korruption in
der Staate LT und und die einzelne
mitliederopie achtung da Kön passier hat
der schwitz schon relativ langit das n
also das in der KE Demokratie da Münder
irgend machen Parteien und Politiker
müssen hier zuande zum ersten Mal
wahlkampfbudges über 50.000 Franken
offen legen und Geldgeber die über 15
000 Franken spenden dürfen sich nicht
mehr
verstecken wir sind unterwegs mit dem
sogenannten fipo Team financement
Politik die drei Männer gehören zur
eitgenössischen Finanzkontrolle kurz EFK
ihre Aufgabe Umsetzung und Kontrolle des
neuen
Gesetzes es ist Ende April das
dreiköpfige Team bietet Schulungen an
für die Parteien wir dürfen kurz Filmen
parat Herr hler ja doch doch wieso macht
die veranstal ja ist neues
Thema für und da git Frage und da macht
das
dass ganz herzlich willkommen zur
Schulung betreffen Transparenz der
politikfinanzierung Hassler und sein
Team Schulen vor allem Leute aus den
parteisekretariaten sie werden dafür
verantwortlich sein Geldflüsse korrekt
zu melden für den Schutz der sensiblen
Daten ist wiederum das fipoeam
zuständig Sicherheit geht nicht
theoretisch immer noch sch aber nicht
vor s sicher D
P die Finanzkontrolle musste diesen Job
übernehmen der Bundesrat hat das so
bestimmt
n sind alle Augen auf die Behörde
gerichtet es gibt Erwartungen und
Kritik mit einem kurzen Auftritt
unterstreicht der Chef der EK Pascal
Stirnimann seine Botschaft an die
Parteien ja wunderbar ich begrüße Sie
und darf sie auch gerade verabschieden
das ist schön die Arbeit hat Herr hler
gemacht ich habe das
Vergnügen und natürlich die zwei
Kollegen als das ist das F Team wir sind
der schmal aufgestellt drei Personen und
ein Punkt ist mir noch ganz wichtig ich
wurde auch vorher kurz drauf
angesprochen ja was gibt's jetzt alles
für Schlupflöcher wo kann man überall
noch ein Weg finden wie man dieses
Gesetz od diese Verordnung umgehen kann
wir werden ih keine Anleitung dazu geben
aber sie sind sicher kreativ aber ich
denke die Message ist wir sind in der
Schweiz doch auch in einem Staat wir
haben ein rechtsverstständnis welches
weniger Regel basiert ist sondern auch
Prinzipien passiert und und der
Grundsatz ist Transparenz in der
pofinanzierung bitte bitte vergessen Sie
das nicht wenn sie für ihre Kandidaten
jeweils die Bücher pflegen das auch
melden dass der Grundsatz transparent
ist also in diesem Sinne besten Dank für
ih Aufmerksamkeit und ich wün ein gute
gute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hereise zwei Monate später es ist
Sommer alle sagen sei das große Geld bei
der
FDP ich warte auf einen freien Moment
von Finanzministerin
Keller mein Auftakt
missglückt ein Wahlkampf kostet viel
Geld das hören wir immer wieder ich will
es von einem FDP Lobbyisten genauer
wissen
ja ja
genau Thema ist ja g im
Wahlkampf ja GD im Wahlkampf spielt g
Rolle also als Begleiter von Kandidatin
und Kandidaten von der Partei ich s ohne
Geld ist es schwieriger konkret wie viel
ja ich sageine Kanton mag das mit ganz
wenig Geld g eine große Kanton wie z s
doch entsprechend wesentlich größer und
lang ze fr nicht 100000 Franken für eine
Nationalratskandidatur und richtig teuer
wäre es für den
Ständerat ich will von bishergen Damian
Müller aus Luzern wissen wie es bei ihm
[Musik]
aussieht sie selber was hab sie für das
BG für der Wahlkampf das Jahr weiß ich
im Moment noch nicht wir sind immer nech
der Evaluation hab sie den so große
spander nein bis jetzt ke so groß SP
erwartet sie nein bis jetzt nicht also
wird gar nicht betreffen doch es wird
mich dahinen betreffen wenn Gesamtbudget
über 50000 Fr
aber der Einzel Spende wenn es über
15000 fr W würde ich
selbverständlich gesetzg
vorfüh ge die
vorstell
W Politik schon lang
sind ich find das Big du musst mit L Z
du
musst am Herz dass sieute wirlich
Überzug was man machen Tatsache ist
nebst der Persönlichkeit und dem
bisherigen Status ist eine Art
Eintrittsticket für eine Wahl ein guter
Listenplatz Plätze mit besseren
Wahlchancen ganz vorne auf der Liste
werden von den Kantonalparteien nach
unterschiedlichen Kriterien vergeben
auch Geld kann eine Rolle spielen die
ncz am Sonntag machte vor über 10 Jahren
publik Topkandidaten der Zürcher
Kantonalpartei mussten damals 4 000
Franken
bezahlen
was Kanton für
lplatz sowieso nicht aber nationalr und
die ander
das
Gen Frage in allen Kantonen fragen wir
sämtliche Parteien an insgesamt
180 140 davon Antworten erstaunlich die
FDP Luz die Sektion von Damian Müller
verlangt Geld für Listenplätze man
benötige das für den gemeinsamen
wahlauftritt sagt die Partei 5000
Franken kostet ein Platz auf der Liste
für die Nominierten für bisherige sogar
7000 Franken ihm werde das als
mandatsträgerbeitrag in Rechnung
gestellt sagt Müll später den neuen als
Kostenbeteiligung im Wahljahr Nachfrage
beim Generalsekretär der FDP
Schweiz gehört das kommt irgendw muss
zahen für die listplatz H ich jetzt vor
ihnen sie noch nie gehört nein nein also
im im krücht aber krüch kommentiere ich
nicht unsere Umfrage zeigt diverse
Kantonalparteien verlangen Geld für
Listenplätze spitzenreiter ist die EVP
in Zürich mit 20.000 Franken für
Listenplatz 1 und 2 dicht gefolgt von
der Mitte Zürich mit 15 000 Franken für
Listen Platz 1 der einztie Spitzenreiter
die FDP Zürich mit damals 40.000 Franken
schreibt uns sie verlange Geld für den
gemeinsamen Wahlkampf nennt aber keinen
Betrag Politik hat mit Macht zu T also
auch mit ökonomischer Macht und insofern
ist Geld tatsächlich wichtig aber was
wesentlich wichtiger ist
Bekanntheit natürlich kann man mit Geld
sich auch bestimmte bekanntheits
schlussze wenn man aber das Amt möchte
lang
Geld ich gehe ins Bundeshaus und möchte
mit jemandem von der FDP Zürich reden in
der Wandelhalle erwische ich den
Kandidaten der im aktuellen Wahlkampf in
Zürich Listen Platz 2 besetzt
Nationalrat Beat Walti unumwunden sagt
er mir was Sache ist das ist be für die
bisherigeinerinen und
4000 Franken und dann g das zurück auf
weiß nicht genau wie viel aber sehr viel
betr hö Betrag 4 fr ich GL man muss
Unterstützer ganz Taschen und kann
einfen und
investiert Kampagne oder dann Umfall
unterstüzt
und endlich daher kommt erstaunt mich
welch große Summen für einen Sitz im
Parlament aufgewendet werden woher
dieses Geld bei Personen und Parteien
kommt da soll also das neue Gesetz Licht
ins Dunkel
bringen den Grundsatz Geldflüsse offen
zu legen egal ob bei Wahlen oder
Abstimmungen finden diese ESP
Nationalrätinnen zwingend
ne ges W du Schl Verantwort B es gibt
Kamp Schwiz zum irgendwo Million her
oder Million her und we das
J die
wir
Parlament einfach nicht sag dass
ke 5000 Franken erhalte sie von
denerchaften
sagttionalr die sie alle immer
und dann gibt es an diesem
wahlkampfanlass ein bisherigen
Quiz
V genau von dem Quiz W Willkür die
Ros Team das
voreschagen alle Kinder und die als Kind
füh
das
[Musik]
bei dieser Spontanaktion frage ich mich
ob solche Ausgaben nun auch verbucht
werden
müssen
spe was meint mein ehemaliger
Arbeitskollege
[Musik]
zu dieselbe Frage an Kandidatin
fello
Kollege im wjahr zum
nach W Briefe versch oder SP
Brief die
m mir natürlich
geh witiger
betr
ma bestandteilon der wkampagne das ist
fr wie Kampagne und Tamara we groß Word
aus g Student gchaff
aberang
viele wichtig nicht wkampf machen
zugegeben die Frage war kleinlich und
trotzdem wo beginnt das neue Gesetz zu
greifen ab welchem Betrag ist eine
Ausgabe für den Wahlkampf budg relevant
da scheint es durchaus Differenzen zu
geben in der
[Musik]
Handhabung hier wird nichts freiwillig
offen
gelegt es ist Anfang
Juli wir treffen als erstes auf
Bundesrat Albert Rösti vor 8 Jahren SVP
Wahlkampfleiter vor 4 Jahren SVP
Präsident grüß
her was h für Budget vor 4 Jahren
das das die Frage W parteell aber den V
das hier off legen warum will das
nicht Rolle vom Bundesrat und jetzt we
wirklich tatsächlich nicht vor vi Jahr
gewusst
Aberg parteibudg
[Musik]
W Herr K Herr darf ich ein bis Frage wir
beginnen jetzt ah
okay
die SVP Schweiz lanciert an dieser
Delegierten Versammlung in Schwiz ihr
Wahlkampfthema die
[Applaus]
[Musik]
migration2 che questa Poli non va Ben la
sign B Schneider
[Applaus]
Dore
wie es um den Einfluss von Geld in der
Politik steht will ich von
Wahlkampfleiter Marcel detling
wissen ich GL in Schwiz m Bürgerin und
Bürger dass es partpende geht das
ist direkt wei Schluss ist von dem oder
ist von dem Verband oder wie auch immer
das ist die Frage das zu das erers
Abstimmen ja Odin das ist die
Frage ich nicht riesen
schen Tag Stund bringen jetzt machen und
der Rest
fr speziell Bezug zu G und ich
respektiere
das beim Thema Geheimhaltung sind die
Reihen innerhalb der Partei be aber
nicht ganz
geschlossen
Politiker ver oder Verband ganz Politik
bevölkchaft
schuldig
wirk
unterstüt ier abrechnen werden
ParlamentarierInnen in jedem Fall egal
ob freiwillig oder nicht erst nach den
Wahlen machen Dokumentarfilm zum Thema
dann noch einmal die Budgetfrage also
das ist effektiv ne Fluss wir sind immer
der Plan für der Kampagne
und
kber
grote Plan
hat parte immer Plan aber
zah Wochen vor der W
bekannt ja
natür V Gehorsam irgendwelche zah
kommunizieren sowieso Fluss sindo
sowieso noch nicht F klar sind der
Wahlkampfleiter meint zum
Thema nicht so schlecht
auslich bes W Angst so Schwiz
plus mit was Plan das wir nicht sagen
aber das W veröffentlichen sobald W das
die 45 t die Hal jed andere zwei Wochen
nach dieser Delegierten Versammlung die
Überraschung die SVP Schweiz enthüllt
viel früher als geplant ihre Zahlen
aufgrund der zahlreichen
journalistenanfragen habe man
kurzfristig entschieden das Budget von
Millionen Franken 100 Tage vor der Wahl
zu kommunizieren schreibt uns die Partei
ab da ist der dam mit der Geheimhaltung
gebrochen jetzt handserz hat sie die
Zahl transparent gemacht W sie nicht
hätte müssen handserz nein hätte wir
nicht ich find es so
relevanteht am Schluss wähl Wählerin und
Wähler so wie es wenn wäh und nicht in
Abhängigkeit vor dem was investiert wird
aber jetzt was alle machen machen
selverständ und haltet eus die regverst
FDP Präsident Terry Burkart auf dem Weg
zu einem Auftritt auch er redet nun
freiwillig offen über Zahlen das Budget
der FDP Schweiz zu diesem Zeitpunkt
2inhal Millionen
Franken es ist der 31 Juli in dieser
argauer Gemeinde wird der 1 August
vorgefeiert alle warten auf ih
hallo
ja
[Gelächter]
gut ja
g mir fällt auf unser Thema die
Transparenz scheint sich nicht als small
Thema zu
eignen Land die notwendige Reformen
inrift damit Erfolgsmodell schwitz auch
in Zukunft Kön inpr in burghartsrede
geht es auch um Geld etwa bei der
Altersvorsorge oder bei der
Stromversorgung kein Wort dagegen zu den
neuen Transparenzregeln und zu den
Finessen in der
Auslegung ganz konkrete Frage
da Zahl wür das wahlkampfbud oder
nichtinst wenn ich w machen ich w
allerings sie D selber zah aber wenn ich
w machen W schon viel
komplizit bur Budget 190 000 Franken
alles fremd finanziert das wde er offen
sagen wenn es denn jemand wissen
wollte g
Transparenz
Inter
was sie
macht
werbemitt hier interessiert man sich
fürs Geld im Wahlkampf bei der
egenössischen Finanzkontrolle kurz
EFK Unterschrift aber es F
[Musik]
statute
Unterschrift gut aber stat F
und
identifizieren undür Person schnell
gemacht juristische
Person berechtig für Partei
unterschrieben und stellen ein fest dass
es sch
anderenständig zestellt wir oder Person
unter
Parteipräsident oder w auch immer dass
das nicht nicht geschickt wird und D mus
wieder nacher
Fragen nicht denkt dass es doch relativ
VT D nach Frage die akrib der EFK hat
einen einfachen Grund sie will
sicherstellen dass keine unautorisierten
Meldungen ins System gelangen die
Nachfragen kommen allerdings nicht
überall gut an das erfahre ich in Arau
imquartier der Mitte argau die
Präsidentin
und Geschäftsführerin haben gerade Post
von Derk
bekommen ist einfach mal und jetzt ist
dass wir die Pass die reich sch
geschickt
zu bewiesen dass du wirklich Präsidentin
bist also was
machen mit Identität der Präsidentin ist
es allerdings nicht getan auch die
Kantonalpartei muss ein detailliertes
Budget
einreichen also und dann muss jeder
Betrag wo meaht über tragen oder ich
muss noch genau ich weiß auch noch nicht
spenden oder
wahspenden ich find das mit der
Transparenz das entsieden und das ist
gut
Aufwand unter der trag oder dem Budget W
wir hab 200000 Franken
W ja so also fr die irgendwie ja gemäß
Umfragen legt die Mitte zu das freut
Marian Binder gemischte Gefühle hat sie
derweil zur Frage was die neuen
Transparenzregeln den wählenden am Ende
wirklich
bringen jetzt das wird sich Wiesen sich
und trag lohnet und ob den auch das
damit erreicht wird wo W die zmenhang
von den große galflüs derl auf
Politik das denn
wirklich wirkig zeigt so Kritik
W nicht gut schlecht ma
mit
probier das umetzen in
der das wird
nicht aber Spektrum extrem breit das
nicht so toll finde und das unbedingt
machen was immer ma immer Kritiker und
mit
M die Bedenken oder sie im vor immer
lerlich und jetzt der Praxis bezogenen
Arbeit dem halbe Jahr werde mir mal
merken was ist jetzt dalich und was
nicht und werden wir genau vtige Frage
mit der glasseiser da kann man sich
lustig machen drüber aber letztlich geht
das den genau der Aufwand wo man
eigentlich handw
vermied bei den großen Spenden sei alles
klar und sinnvoll bei den Details nicht
was gehört ins budg was
nicht
es
nicht s im Sommer
natürlichsicht und dann ist bestandon
der Kampagne aber das Schar geh das
[Musik]
das em nächsten
Auftritt auch hier wird der 1 August
[Musik]
vorgefeiert die jüngsten Wahlprognosen
verheißen nichts Gutes für die FDP es
könnte zu einem Kopf an Kopf Rennen
kommen und Platz 3 zwischen der FDP und
mittea die
gr Land und W und
Watten sehr gernock wen zu
Geld
unfassbareleld erhten haben ein wochenor
dieünen Konzern Sika schenkt ihnen 1
Million Franken das Geld von garmita
Burkard Kröber wird offiziell die größte
Spende in diesem Wahlkampf bleiben
Präsident Baltasar glattli nutzt den
Moment für
Wahlwerbung ich treffe ihn auf eine
trampfahrt in
[Applaus]
Zürich grüne wo z Jahr Mitglied ist hat
sich entschlossen grüne so grß W machen
die grö Geschichte Million W nie auf die
IDE dass sie so viel wir spenden nein
das ist für mich riesige Überraschung
wachsgeschenk grermaß fest macht das
abhängig von der Spenderin überhaupt
nicht mir wüssen das ist ein einmalige
spend ein klaren Zweck auf die W h und
entsprechend sie auch verwenden und
sezig wo hoffentlich n starke grüne
Fraktion im National und im Ständer eine
schier unlösbare Aufgabe gemäß Prognose
verlieren die Grünen deutlich eine
mobilisierungsapp realisiert mit der
millionenpende soll
helfen dann W sie und wir wür trotzdem
natürlich nutzen also sich nicht sag ich
gut und
geh für die Million habe er sichlich mit
handgeschriebenen Brief bei der
Spenderin
bedankt was viel und wenig Geld ist und
je nach Perspektive wie relativ das
alles damit sind wir während dieser
Schweizerreise immer wieder
[Musik]
konfrontiert
Familie Kandidatin Tamara ficello stellt
uns Ihren Zitat Großspender vor ich bin
älter was das absolut und ich muss nicht
g
traditionelle Muster
verfahre die vorstö extremistisch nach
wie vor
Reaktion und drum ist die Politik Tamara
macht nicht n gchtfertig unbedingt
notwendig und S die Stimmen im Parlament
und
absolut sich für die
unter Martin Krebs kenne sie von der
Gewerkschaftsarbeit sagt ficello mehr
nicht gespendet habe er ihr noch nie
etwas und das Problem das zum
starketchaft aber mir l das
und
Politikerin im Parlament
[Applaus]
danke
und 500 hat an einen W
bezahlt sie erzählt mir von Skrupel
wegen dieser
Spende not bring
[Gelächter]
mit
urampre
diskutiert so große
SP für
okay diskutiertum sch
ja
ganz ja das das ich
für
für Sichtweise was aber wenn Spender
nicht mit Namen hinstehen wollen und
nicht mehr Spenden aus
politikwissenschaftlicher Perspektive
die andere Position Schwiz ist ein
eigenartiges Land da R man nicht so gern
über Geld mir GT zwar Geld gern aber mir
möchten nicht unbedingt auffallen und
wenn man weiß dass Partei bis zu 90%
halt einfach von Fremdmittel abhängig
sind dann könte Sie dass die
Transparenzregeln jetzt könnte dazu
führen dass Parteien nicht me so viel
Geld hab und Partei eine wichtige Rolle
Spiel im Milizsystem schwitz könnte das
Transparenzgesetz allfalls negative
Folge 20 Plakat will heiß Schu sind
und
sinder ja gut bei der Mitte hat das neue
Gesetz offiziell keinen namhaften
Einfluss auf Spendengeld während die
Mitte Arau wahplakate sortiert nim mich
wunder was so eine Kandidatur mindestens
kostet Briefversand macht
unterstützbefversand oder ist
schnell fr dann die Plakat
Plakat fr kostet den sch W
alles plak
S ist das Z derauermitte und möchte neu
in den Ständerat Ihr Budget 150 000
fren das Leist gut Teil DAV ist
natürlich auch wieder als meine ich bin
jetzt ja auch
nationalr das ist nicht so dass man da
gar nicht verdient also kan Teil wieder
reinvestier völlig mittellos W
die vi jah wieder Kön in Bern wenn Sie
das wett oh persönlich commitment Gott
das natürlich nicht wen jetzt sag
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
allepar dive Möglichkeiten illegale und
legale an diesem Fest m im Sommer lerne
ich letzteres
[Musik]
kennen
und ich treffe SVP Nationalrat er Hess
einer der mit Transparenz im Wahlkampf
nichts anfangen kann
über die
50000 eigentlich nicht das
deklarationsp was meint er mit
eigentlich im Gesetz steht Spenden
über000 fren die in den Letten
monenorm g müssen deklariert werden
Freund und Wahlkampfhelfer Thomas Fuchs
hat es vor dem Stichtag 15000 Franken
gespendet eine schlaumeerei
entlich
aberch
oktoberchoktober aber die ganze
[Musik]
transparenzull
nicht deklarations
V wie viel
vorhero wo so V her we nicht ganz genau
wer wer werund von der
Gesamtausgabe Gesamtausgabe muss
sowieso
genau nicht
richtigar nicht so
schlecht
die Transparenz legal umgehen das machen
auch die ganz großen die Kampagne von
economy Swiss Bauernverband Arbeitgeber
und Gewerbeverband heißt Perspektive
Schweiz und startet exakt vor der
Transparenz
Deadline
fr die Absol Transparenz oder Prinzip
schon transparen vor und sie vollständig
W Kontrolle es ist Mitte September
Infoveranstaltung der Finanzkontrolle
für die Medien wir sind jetzt ein genau
einen Monat vor den Wahlen die Daten
sind vorhanden die Plattform
funktioniert man kann diese Daten
abrufen und dem her sind wir hier und
Track kann man sagen die gelddaten sind
noch roh ohne Schlussabrechnung
unkontrolliert die parteibudgs kantonal
und
aufgerechnetgeben FDP und SVP haben am
meisten Geld je über 10 Millionen
Franken es s einfach Spekulationen
sondern sie
fakte viel Information das Bit
stimmbürgerin und stimb ich
zwi aber das gewünscht de istch und
jetzt was
da aus dem neuen Register lässt sich
einiges
rauslesen auch wenn die große
Überraschung ausbleibt Greenpeace
Schweiz z.B stellt mitarbeiterleistungen
in der Höhe von 85 000 Franken für eine
Wahlzeitung oder der ehemalige
autoimporteur Walter frei gibt
Kandidierenden der SVP eine viertel
Million Franken für den Wahlkampf
verantwortlich für die Angaben im System
sind die meldepflichtigen ob alles
stimmt oder Tricks angewendet wurden
muss die EFK nun prüfen manehikel
zwisescht um etwas zu verschleihen od
und wenn das wir dann zum Schluss kommen
be Kontrollen dass das der Fall ist oder
dann ist es qu dann haben wir ein Medien
spekulieren schon über mögliche Fälle
z.B verschleiert die SVP
Gönnervereinigung Stiftung für
bürgerliche Politik die Namen ihrer
Großspender oder die Demo für Kaufkraft
einen Monat vor den Wahlen die
Gewerkschaft sagt kein wahlkampfanlass
und deklariert nichts ein Fall für die
Finanzkontrolle die klimademo 3 Wochen
vor den Wahlen wird deklariert
337000 Franken hat die klimaallianz im
Register
eingetragen mir persönlich we
und parte versuchen wir natürlich auch
wir sindonder beobacht mir immer die
transparenzf prech wsen dass besonders
gut aber kundigt ich bin überzeugt
machen nicht n so gut wie möglich
sondern richtig 10000 kommen an diese
Demon doch gemäß Prognose sieht es für
die Grünen nach wie vor düster
aus zurück bei der Finanzkontrolle Herr
H konkret erkl wie der prüf das wer wir
so nicht
sagen aber natürlich schon Plan Konzept
wir d mit die Stichprobe WW und
sicherlich herusforder wir wer n Zahl
externe konfrontieren Interview führe
und investigative
abkff es TRT eine maximale Geldstrafe
von 40.000 Franken und
Reputationsschaden das heißt
stichprobewies aber ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass wenn Partei Z find wieso
jetzt gerade mir und die andere n dass
das wieder zu politische Diskussion Kön
führeen und n demokratiethoretische
Perspektive sind poltis Diskussion
eigentlich nur
[Musik]
positiv was das neue Transparenzregister
auch zeigt er hat viel und
ausschließlich eigenes Geld für sich und
die Parteien den Wahlkampf gesteckt
Thomas mat Nationalrat und Finanzchef
der
SVP gemäß Bilanz gehört Thomas mat zu
den 33en Schweizern wie kommt man zu
solch einem Reichtum
[Musik]
also ich wür sagen primär hat das mit
schick ich h ich
z rankfleg wer
unbedingtrankfleg aber mE Elter krank
das ist das ist also nicht negative
nicht aber was machst in die Zukunft
krankfleg schlechtaht so
Dank
ichents rankfleger Word der bker ja ich
habe
J man sich
Hal er hat Geld sie nicht 160 000
Franken ohne einen rappenspendengeld hat
mat für sich in den Wahlkampf gesteckt
tamara ficello hat ihre 40 000 Franken
fast nur mit Spendengeld
erreicht kurz vor den Wahlen macht sie
ihren wichtigsten spendenanlass ein drag
Bingo
das durchch im Bundesrat etwas über 5000
Franken muss sie hier sammeln sonst
klappt nicht mit dem
Budget Sicherheit
aber ne die Sicherheit ist nicht probier
einfach aber dass es wampf hat zum
finanziell Risiko füh das ist klar
ja her
tamaraello großp
sieön ja das ist sehr viel Geld
ja Franken ist für
monlohpr wir fahren mit Thomas Matzer an
einen
wahlkampfanlass
viel ja ich meine me g Z und ich will
jetzt das G so
wir zu aber das ist jetzt mir
nicht finanziell und politisch trennen
und ficello
Welten se schon wie ich hier allmählich
politisiert ich habe gehört versammel
sich immer
wieder
das
undum zum Auftrag macht wichtig D W W ma
so wkampf machen dass sie un stim und
der Plattform de
[Musik]
baukampf schö
Plakat
vor
mit
sagen
das G
S und
jetzt mit Leuten aus der Partei und
seiner Frau verteilt er mitten
in
mit wer schafft es für die Wiederwahl
ich ma was immer ich ma ma ich für für m
Kinder
undkeler ich B aufwachsen wunderschöne
Land von fre L auf wel Kinder und
hoffenter
schz bei ihr wird es mit der Wahl knapp
werden nicht
l der
Politik
mus Tag gut kommt oder nicht das ist
einfach nicht gut für Politik
macht
nicht wahtag Zahltag wer bestimmt in den
kommenden vi Jahren die Politik der
Schweiz
die große Siegerin die SVP sie hatte ein
großes Budget und wohl mindestens so
wichtig ihr Thema die Migration hat
verfangen die Grünen stürzen geradezu ab
ihre großspenderin wollte das Gegenteil
eine starke grüne Fraktion im Bundeshaus
ob ihre Million noch Schlimmeres
verhindert
hat Thierry burgharts FDP hatte
offiziell das höchste Budget die Mitte
mit rund einem Drittel weniger Geld
konnte er nicht auf Abstand
[Applaus]
halten im Gegenteil die Mitte hat
aufgeholt und jubelt neuer Name neues
Glück gemäß Hochrechnungen rund 1% Punkt
mehr für die SP schließlich bedeutet die
Niederlage der Grünen mehrähler Teile
tamaraicello kann zum Zeitpunkt dieser
Aufnahmen aber noch nicht entspannen
ihre Wiederwahl ist weiter unsicher
übrigens laut offiziellen Aussagen der
Parteien ging das Spendenvolumen wegen
des neuen transparenzgesetzes nicht
zurück was es gebracht hat die Bilanz
folgt im neuen Jahr es Kön zwei Sache
passierere auf der S hab wir jetzt die
Reg und das passiert einfach nicht oder
irgendwann find da ist es vergehen
passiert und dann popt das vielleicht
wird allfalls verschärft also es gibt
jetzt so um gmöglichkeit wo man d
vielleicht irgendwn find ne das GT n das
Reg das ist cool dass das passiert in
der Demokratie Entscheid ist nie egültig
mich immer wieder drüber diskutiere muss
aber immer wieder beobachte ja was
passiert wir haben festgestellt die
anfängliche Hemmung offen über Geld zu
reden ist zusehens
erodiert und nicht nur politafine wissen
jetzt Wahlkampf kostet sehr viel
Geld und wer weiß vielleicht führt die
gesetzlich erzwungene Transparenz sogar
dazu dass SpenderInnen dereinst stolz
verkünden wem sie ihr Geld
[Musik]
geben